[Music]
thank you
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
let's talk about our democracy for a
minute
but let's do it in a way that makes the
snowflakes heads explode let me be clear
before this podcast begins we are loud
proud and do not give a [ __ ]
this is the Tony Michaels podcast real
and raw political and social commentary
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ]
eating [ __ ] ah the smell of freedom of
speech this is the Tony Michaels podcast
and this is Tony Michaels
hey Tony [ __ ] them
[Music]
puff puff pass [ __ ]
dank Brandon lights up again
I love how the ride thinks that this is
not gonna be popular people are not
gonna be into this
this is not a thing that white people
are gonna put up with what are you
talking about Lauren Laurie Ingram goes
on Fox news last night I'm going to show
you the clip leader this is hilarious
it's the dumbest thing I've ever heard
in my life
she's like if you I mean unless you're
wanting to elect Democrats if you elect
Democrats They're Gonna Give You pot
porn abortion and more January 6th
select committee hearings
it sounded like a [ __ ] party to me
sounds like a good [ __ ] time
sounds like exactly what the country
wants like pot porn access to Medical
Care and accountability for the [ __ ]
Traders you got it baby see you're
telling me we get to watch porn smoke
pot while while the Traders get
accountability and everyone has access
to medical care life-saving treatments
foreign
straight into the [ __ ] point and
don't get it all the time it's on brand
for them on brand for them
when I heard this yesterday
I figured most of Americans it took them
all all of 30 seconds to realize that
Joe Biden
had pardoned all federal possession
charges of marijuana
like that's what that's their plan now
there's three steps to it but that is
the thing everyone heard
everybody heard that basically Joe
Biden's gonna make pot legal
decriminalize possession of marijuana
which he should whatever the [ __ ] he can
do and the federal government can do to
decriminalize possession of marijuana
and let these let these marijuana
operations that are responsible operate
what the [ __ ] are you it's already legal
in the states and there's going to be
more States legalizing it in this next
election
recreationally not just medically
recreationally
it's going to be on the ballot
and they're going to do it
it's a popular thing
to not criminalize smoking a [ __ ]
Leaf off a plant or the bud sorry I
don't I don't really I don't smoke
marijuana we're gonna get our uh our
weed expert on today uh Gabe Sanchez he
knows a little more about the Dank than
I do I I I'm marijuana is not my drug of
choice I don't have anything against it
just I just don't I don't know just I
think I don't like to smoke I I I'm a
I'm a former cigarette smoker
and I know you can eat Edibles and all
that stuff and I've never explored those
Avenues
but I'm I'm a former cigarette smoker I
don't smoke anymore it's been over 10
years since I've smoked cigarettes
but when you're a cigarette smoker
you once one you're always one right so
you're always
will desire a cigarette and it's not
necessarily the the nicotine it's it's
the taste it's the feeling it's the
smoke Rising right
it's maybe more what you're addicted to
The Habit
of it I mean even in my dreams when I
dream of myself when I can remember my
dreams
depending on how much alcohol I've had
if I can remember myself and my dreams
I see myself and I'm smoking so I'm I'm
still a smoker
I just choose not to smoke cigarettes
because it's [ __ ] disgusting and
it'll it'll kill you
I mean we know these these facts maybe
one of these days when I'm on my
deathbed maybe I'll light up again
but I went to a wedding several years
back and I realized that I can't smoke
anything I can't actually smoke anything
because I went to a wedding
um several years ago and they had a
cigar bar at one of my buddies weddings
and I was like oh I'll Have a Cigar so I
cut the cigar and lit the cigar and took
about two pops off cigar and realized
that was a really bad idea I liked it
way too much way too much and that is
the road back to buying packs of
cigarettes which is not a thing that I
want to do
so
so I don't I don't do the whole smoking
marijuana but I think it's ridiculous
that people in this country are [ __ ]
Crim lines because they want to enjoy a
plant
in plant form
it's not like they're [ __ ] doing
anything crazy with this [ __ ]
it's a it's a plant
Joe Biden knows it dank parandon knows
it I don't know how many how many
different uh alter alternate
personalities do you think Joe Biden's
gonna have before this is over with
I have no idea there's dark Brandon
there's dank Brandon speaking of dark
Brandon go get your dark Brandon
Merchant store.d20michaels.com I have a
special announcement I'm waiting
literally waiting right now I'm waiting
on our dank Brandon design like right
now I'm waiting on it I got it it's
coming I promise we're gonna have dank
Brandon merch
within this hour
probably within the show for sure
not only will we have date Brandon on
the merch store
but we will have it we will have a
Graphic for you even I might even have
some music for it I don't know
but stay tuned here on the Tony Michaels
podcast today so you can see our
exclusive dank Brandon design
because we have to celebrate this
because this isn't just a celebration to
smoke marijuana and get high
okay
this is a step in the direction that the
country should have took decades ago we
could have saved gazillions of dollars
on the deficit which the Republicans are
going to [ __ ] about
maybe one of these days they'll get back
to bitching method deficit they're
really concentrated on children's
genders and genitalia and how they
identify and what books they're reading
they can't stop focusing on children
they're obsessed it's really [ __ ]
weird but they're obsessed with it
maybe one of these days they'll get back
to the debt and deficit
maybe their obsession
but we could have saved so much money so
much heartache so much time so many
people's lives over a [ __ ] plant
Joe Biden knows it
he knows it's the most reasonable thing
to do for the federal government to say
look all these states are legalizing
this [ __ ]
we might as well give the the the
businesses out there that are
responsible and legitimate the
opportunity to actually do business at
Banks
[ __ ] stupid ass [ __ ] that they can't
do business at Banks
so not only is he pardoning
The Possession the federal charges of
possession which is ridiculous that the
feds even charge people with possession
it's [ __ ] stupid now not not the
dealing or the the distribution of this
drug
that is marijuana
um
it's just the possession now I think he
should move further and I I hope the
government will move further
into uh distribution and stuff and
consider some of these pardons
for people who distribute
and deal the drug which is still even
kind of [ __ ] ridiculous
but the other move that Joe Biden is
making is he's directing
the federal government to reschedule
and to look at rescheduling this drug
which is the most important part about
it all really I mean I mean the pardons
are good because you can fix what you
have done wrong to the folks who had
simply had non-violent possession of a
plant
okay
listen I prefer alcohol over marijuana
and alcohol is a much more dangerous
drug much more dangerous drug
and to the person and the people around
them
I mean what the [ __ ] is
what the [ __ ] is marijuana gonna do
make you violently eat a bag of bunions
come on now
everyone everyone knows about marijuana
at this point
and frankly frankly White America loves
marijuana so this idea that Fox News is
trying to push of
legalizing pot is going to draw us into
some kind of Anarchy or some [ __ ] you
are some dumb of you definitely I don't
know how weed works that much because I
don't smoke it I've never smoked it that
much but you definitely don't know how
it works never been around someone high
on [ __ ] marijuana if you think that
people smoking pot is gonna draw us into
Anarchy you are a dumb son of a [ __ ]
and you definitely don't know what the
hell you're talking about
you need to get out more
frankly you're the people that need to
start smoking
do some pup pup pass
and get high you [ __ ] need to
get high experience some [ __ ] Jesus
[ __ ] Christ
thinking that a bunch of potheads are
gonna cause Anarchy in this country
what
oh and this Gateway [ __ ] right
that's yeah they're gonna start saying
that [ __ ] you're gonna hear that word a
lot over the next 30 days gateway drug
gateway gateway gateway gateway
you're gonna hear that [ __ ] a lot
oh [ __ ] Hunter Biden and Don Jr already
trending
and they're doing coke not [ __ ]
marijuana I mean they probably smoke
marijuana but they're doing coke a whole
nother [ __ ] ball wax
but this is good for the country
and really honestly
no one's paid attention
to Joe Biden other than gas prices and
now marijuana think about this there are
a lot of Americans out there that don't
even know who the vice president is they
have no clue no clue don't know who the
Attorney General is
have no idea about any of the criminal
cases going on they don't know who owns
a laptop and who doesn't own a laptop
they don't give a [ __ ]
they've got their jobs they've got their
kids they've got sporting events school
events are taking their kids to they
watch football on the weekends
they watch their stupid [ __ ] reality
shows all week long they got and they
gotta cook dinner do laundry clean the
[ __ ] house they got [ __ ] to do
they ain't got time to worry about who's
who's got a laptop and who doesn't
but I'll tell you one thing I'll tell
you one thing that happened yesterday
everyone in this country went Joe Biden
did what with marijuana
it was kind of like a national oh what
you're saying
this you mean this branding guy this guy
named Brandon he'll let me love who I
want to love
he'll let me watch porn
he'll let me smoke pot
and he'll he'll get rid of my student
debt
what's so bad what the hell is so bad
literally that is what they're gonna
remember
if Joe Biden is on the ballot anywhere
in this country and what I mean by that
is he's not actually on the ballot but
if Republicans are successful at tying
any Democratic candidate to Joe Biden
think about this
think about this for a second
Joe Biden is going to be known for
letting he's totally okay with you
letting you love who you want to love
which most Americans are for that
they do not give a [ __ ]
if you want to love who you want to love
as long as you're not telling them what
the [ __ ] to do
right
and now they're gonna now they're gonna
remember that their he's canceling
everyone's student debt he's going to
cancel your student debt just get rid of
it unless the Republicans have anything
to do about it then no they'll let you
they'll make you pay it [ __ ]
and now and now he's gonna let you smoke
pot I mean basically that's what they
heard right
they're not gonna dive deep enough into
this to know every single aspect of what
Joe Biden said they don't have time
that's what we're dealing with here
that's the people we have to convince
that's what I keep telling you got to
lean into democracy so these
[ __ ] who don't have time to pay
attention to politics like you do
because they're paying attention to
other [ __ ] regardless of you know how
ridiculous it is and how
unimportant it really is to the grand
scheme of things that's what they're
doing
those are the people you gotta [ __ ]
get in front of and wave your arms
around and go hey hey man you're gonna
vote you're going to vote for the people
who who are trying to make sure that you
continue to pay your student debt
who were absolutely obsessed with
children's gender and their identities
and banning books in schools
want to take your [ __ ] rights away
from you and definitely don't want you
to [ __ ] have a plant
or smoke it for that matter
they want you to go to prison over a
plant
or you can go with the Democrats who
actually they don't give a [ __ ] if you
get high they don't give a [ __ ] if you
get high they don't care who you love
more power to you whatever you want to
do that's cool and they'll cancel your
student debt and oh by the way they're
going to concentrate on your children's
education not what books they can band
and what's in their [ __ ] britches
this is all this is the [ __ ] you need to
get in front of people and wave your
arms around over the next 30 days
and really honestly you need to do it
sooner than that today is a great day
because uh voter registration is going
to close up here and everyone needs to
go check their registration this is
super important to go check your
registration today
call your voting Precinct County
whatever you got to do however you do it
in your state every State's a little
different but you need to check your
registration because these [ __ ]
Republicans have been purging people
from the polls
from the voter rolls I should say
and you don't want to show up
on Election Day on November 8th and
discover
that your vote doesn't count
because they cheated because definitely
a hundred percent all the cheating in
this next election is going to be 100 a
republican 100 [ __ ] percent I mean
maybe
99.9999999999
there might be one [ __ ] one
Democrat tries to vote twice one
and of everybody do not do that by the
way do not do that do not do not trust
me when I say this you don't want to go
to prison over something dumb like
election fraud just go vote
if you have a legal right to vote go do
it that you can do that it's legal to
vote
but you got to check your registration
and not only check your registration but
make sure your friends are doing it as
well don't let them be complacent and
just think well I've never had problems
with my registration [ __ ] yeah
you've never had [ __ ] fascists trying
to take over the country and steal an
election well I mean we have
but not to the extent that they're going
to try to do it this time
and a good conversation starter is this
[ __ ] marijuana thing
I know it feels dumb and stupid but who
gives a [ __ ] whatever it [ __ ] takes
whatever it takes folks
how how [ __ ] boneheaded do you have
to be
to be against
[ __ ] smoking a plant in the
privacy of their own home
how [ __ ] dumb is this [ __ ] that
you're gonna be against that get the
[ __ ] out of here with that nonsense
you aren't gonna run into too many
[ __ ] that you want to be around
more than 10 12 seconds that are gonna
be against it
you're just not
so I don't know if the administration's
timing on this was planned but if it was
you gotta hand it to the the Biden
Administration if this was planned to
time like this this is beautiful and
perfect of course you know they're all
wanting to talk about [ __ ] Hunter
Biden and what he said about Putin
today because they definitely do not
want the American people to be
distracted by the fact that dank Brandon
wants them to get high
entire Generations entire Generations in
this country were built on this plant
and the idea
that you could get a little relief from
your stress in your life maybe pain all
kinds of stuff from this this magical
little plant
by smoking it by eating it
and they've criminalized it for decades
wanna stick you in prison
because you want to sit on your couch
watch a movie smoke some weed
and eat some Funyuns
the [ __ ] out of here with this [ __ ]
you don't think that America will wake
up
and
and smell the Kush
foreign
this is a great way to go out and start
talking to your friends your family your
community members
it's a great conversation starter
what's better
did you hear the Joe Biden
is wanting to decriminalize marijuana
legalize marijuana however you want to
say it doesn't matter
even they say oh you're a liar who gives
a [ __ ] who gives a [ __ ]
this is a great subject and it's it's
perfectly timed again I don't know if
the administration timed this I have no
idea
I'm sure it took many many months to
figure out exactly how this partnering
thing would work
because they got to figure out how many
of these charges he would actually
pardon
uh what the what the I mean they got to
figure out what the effect would be to
the system like how because it's going
to take assets and time to do this it's
not just gonna
you know just boom be done they gotta
figure out the structure of it he's not
just going to Tweet this [ __ ] out like
the last dumb [ __ ]
he gets an ID in his head and tweets it
out I'm sure they have thought this
through thoroughly now again I'm not
sure the timing on it
but it's perfectly time for you to lean
into your democracy and start talking
about it
the gifts just keep on coming and folks
the Republicans are going to serve up so
many gifts on this in the next few weeks
we got so many debates that are gonna
happen
and these dumb [ __ ] are going
to stand in front of microphones talking
about how we shouldn't be legalizing
marijuana and it's bad it's a gateway
drug and it's horrible for you
when probably half their constituency
who is the ones likely to vote for them
are already smoking it and don't want it
criminalized
it's beautiful
and if it is timed if this
Administration did time this decision
now
to make sure that this happened before
the election
that they sped this along to get it
announced and get it this program to be
rolled out before the election holy [ __ ]
every everyone has complained for years
and years about Democratic messaging
and it has it's it's been pretty shitty
they're not willing to say the things
you got to say to win they're just not
they haven't been but they are now
and if this is just happenstance or this
was planned to be rolled out before the
midterm [ __ ] great good go use it
because all these [ __ ] can
concentrate on today is how some dumb
son of a [ __ ] who said Matt gatz wasn't
going to be charged for human
trafficking and sex trafficking Hunter
Biden is going to be charged
for tax evasion
they're all they're screaming about
Hunter Biden screaming about it
who's got a laptop who doesn't have a
laptop it's really dumb [ __ ]
even Alan dershowitz
was on I think it was Newsmax and he
called him Biden Jr
they've been saying the words Hunter
Biden for [ __ ] months and months and
months and months and money years
they've been saying 100 by it and Hunter
by the laptop 100 by 100 and under
biting this hundred biting that
our country's going to hell in a
handbasket cause a hunter button
and Alan Durst would call them Biden Jr
I didn't understand that he must have
turned around the [ __ ] crackheads or
something
he kind of combined two crackheads Don
Jr Hunter Biden Jr I think that's what
he did
he took the two crackhead Sons no one
gives a [ __ ] about 100 Biden
by the way who honestly if Hunter Biden
committed tax evasion fine charge him
whatever go to court he'll plead guilty
and he he might he might get a prison
sentence
for tax evasion
and lying to the FBI
this is the same [ __ ] that Donald Trump
is being charged with the same tax
evasion is the same type of charges that
the Trump organization is criminally
charged with
in New York
what the [ __ ] is going on why are these
people yelling and screaming about
Hunter Biden committing tax evasion yes
so what if he's if he criminally did it
fine charge him whatever if a United
States Attorney if a prosecutor feels
that they're privy that Hunter by Junior
should be charged with tax evasion
because he did it criminally fine what
what do we give a [ __ ] he's not the
president of the United States
nor does he have much influence over him
at all
other than other than his dad loves him
which is what the majority of the Trump
world is really jealous about
that that dank Brandon has empathy
and decency and he loves his children
unlike the other [ __ ] the former
guy the Cheeto dust mobster he [ __ ]
hates those son [ __ ]
and they [ __ ] hate him they're
willing to turn on him
when you see that probably in a couple
grand juries or we're going to witness
that in a couple grand juries but here's
the thing
Hunter Biden
[ __ ] obsessed [ __ ] Hunter
Biden if he were to be charged with tax
evasion is the same type of charge that
the Trump organization is criminally
charged with
in York it's a different type of tax I'm
sure but it's tax evasion now
Trump and his children
Trump and his children are you following
along you Hunter Biden laptop dummies
are civilly in a lawsuit
for tax evasion with the state of New
York better they are likely to lose
because it's a much lower bar than the
criminal charge
and not only that
the CFO of the Trump organization
the [ __ ] company that Trump and his
children run
has pled guilty to tax evasion schemes
which is what this bonehead that I don't
know who the [ __ ] this person this
anonymous source is and maybe they're
right who gives a [ __ ] if they're right
or not
if you're so concerned you Hunter Biden
laptop dummies you morons out there who
can't stop talking about Hunter Biden
if you're so concerned about tax evasion
maybe maybe Focus your energy on the
cases that are already pending that have
already been filed
really is some dumb ass [ __ ]
but what do you expect what do you
expect
from these manga Republicans other than
what about ism
because I got that yes I got that
yesterday because I I ordered this
morning I don't know I tweeted this this
out
about how these boneheads are so focused
on Hunter Biden when a tax evasion of
Hunter Biden when it's Trump and his
organizations that are actually charged
with that already
they're charged with it
and then this morning with the center
Biden lamp top stuff and Hunter Biden
stuff it's not the laptop you just get
this language in my head and the reason
why is because I always tweet out that
Hunter Biden's laptop is like its own
little entity
because they seem like it is
as if
if you own a laptop you're a criminal
what the [ __ ] are you talking who
doesn't own a laptop or hadn't had a
laptop before
it's really stupid [ __ ] it's dumb stupid
[ __ ]
but I tweeted out the hunter Biden
if he really is evading taxes that's
exactly what the Trump children the
Trump organization and Trump himself are
accused of doing in New York and they're
charged with it
and they have lawsuits filed against
them for it for the same type of [ __ ] so
if it's so bad it's so bad why why is it
not so bad there why
why
well that's what about ISM Tony I'm what
about is it what are you talking about
you people are completely focused on an
anonymous source which
remind you the same [ __ ] the
same [ __ ] who didn't believe in
anonymous source that came out and said
real true [ __ ] now that we know that's
all the [ __ ] truth about Donald Trump
who were leaker they're leakers remember
they're leakers
they're woke leakers I guess those are
leakers who leak information
about the government and Trump
but now now they're they must be taken
seriously all Anonymous sources must be
taken seriously
I mean when it's against Hunter Biden
or in favor of Matt Getz
we have to take that leak seriously
you see that you see the problem that
they have here you've seen the the
corner that they're boxing themselves
into
this it's the same Corner that Donald
Trump is boxing himself into with these
documents
it's really stupid [ __ ] of course you
see on the TV behind me they can't stop
talking the media buys into this [ __ ]
Hook Line Sinker the stupid Hunter Biden
[ __ ]
who gives a [ __ ] who cares charge him if
he [ __ ] committed crimes what do I
give a [ __ ]
he's not the president he's not on the
White House staff he's not running Joe
Biden's businesses that he's [ __ ]
he's [ __ ] criminally using our
government to to dump money into our
money that's not what's happening you
stupid bastards that is what was
happening under the last [ __ ]
the outrage machine is a little
unbalanced here you Hunter Biden laptop
idiots
yeah but they'll never pluck their heads
out of their asses it just won't happen
boy I'm waiting on this uh this dank
Brandon
uh
art to come in so we can show you this
merch hopefully we'll have it today
today's Friday you know what Friday is
you know what happens every Friday here
at the Tony Michaels podcast
bonehead of the week
we got some [ __ ] boneheads for you in
the second hour me and Gabe Sanchez my
co-host will go through bonehead of the
week you vote you decide bone end of the
week and we break it down every single
Friday in the second hour of the Tony
Michaels podcast
and today's Friday
so stay tuned here's the dark Brandon
uh art again stored at the attorney
michaels.com our dank Brandon merch is
on the way I promise it's on the way
and we run on your support rather you
buy dark or dank Brandon merch or you go
to Tony michaels.live tip Tony Michaels
dot live and you can leave a tip for us
there one time or you can set it up
monthly we appreciate all the support
you give rather you give a tip by merch
you guys have been buying the hell out
of this merch holy [ __ ] you guys love
the new Liberty
design the freedom to oppress the rights
of other people is not Liberty you
shit-eating [ __ ]
you guys know it into the intro
but there's the shirt and this one is
flying off the shelves I think it's
because it doesn't have any curse words
on it and the messaging is like the
entire messaging behind the show the
freedom to oppress the rights of other
people is not Liberty
you must lean into democracy so if you
want to lean into democracy and support
the show go to store.d Tony michaels.com
and grab your Liberty shirt today
the Dank Brandon merch I promise it's
incoming maybe we'll have it within the
next half hour well I'm hoping we'll
have it by bonehead of the week for sure
I'm hoping we'll have Graphics I'll be
able to show it to you I I promise I
think well I should promise but I'm
waiting on the design the final design
to come in but you guys are gonna love
this you're gonna love the design so
stick around everybody we're gonna go
through the shitless Roundup and then to
Bone end of the week at the top of the
hour
stick around we'll be right back right
after these messages
we'll be right back Mark
60 seconds this is the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
are you numb and alone after storming
the capital have you been left out in
the cold after stealing Nancy Pelosi's
mail do you feel exposed to a government
that doesn't share your patriotic values
if any of these describe you then you're
in luck hi I'm Paul gosar and thanks to
my new product pardon blanket I've got
you covered part in blanket specifically
Works to make you feel safe and cozy
after your involvement on January 6th
and if you're one of the other members
of Congress who also helped with the
attempted coup hard and blanket will
protect you too hard in blanket is made
of a sort of soft fleece and a layer of
sheep's wool and they're a hundred
percent made in the USA don't delay and
get your pardon blanket today for just
99.99 actual pardons not guaranteed
jumping back into it this is the Tony
Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show thanks for
sticking through the break
Friday Friday Friday
what else is going to get high this
weekend
thanks Brandon thanks Brandon
well the dark Landing is great but the
Dank Brandon I don't know this may catch
even more leagues
than anything
the entire country yesterday went well
wait wait wait wait wait wait
so this branding guy he's gonna let me
love who I want to love
he's gonna cancel my student debt
and he's gonna let me smoke pot
what's the problem again describe it to
me the problem
it really is something it really is
something here the the
um the messaging what the country wants
what the country needs what the
country's interested in
I mean it's the it's the honest truth I
don't know how more to put it when
Republicans are more focused on
stripping away a woman's right to
medical procedures to save their lives
when when Republicans are trying to ban
books when Republicans are more focused
on the children's genitalia and their
sexual identities than their education
it's really [ __ ] weird [ __ ]
they can't stop their passing laws about
it Jesus Christ
in Florida apparently they want to track
teenage athletes women athletes
periods or some [ __ ] what is this I
don't even know what this is again I
don't I'm I'm not a woman okay hey hey
you [ __ ] stupid ass white dudes out
there
I'm not a woman
so I don't get involved
and want to control their issues
stay out of it stay the [ __ ] out of it
and really honestly from that story I
would tell any woman anywhere because I
I didn't really buy into this whole um
tracking app thing
because I again I'm a woman I don't no
I'm not a woman I do not know anything
about it I just don't know
I don't have the experience
so I I try not to
but I I didn't know that these tracking
apps where you're tracking your period
but apparently you definitely should
take that [ __ ] off your phone
take that [ __ ] off your phone
delete it delete the data grab the data
tell them to delete it
do not have that [ __ ] apparently
especially in a state where these
Republicans have control and that's why
it's so important to engage it is so
[ __ ] important right now in this next
month to get out there and lean into
democracy because on November 8th you're
gonna either choose
democracy or autocracy
and believe you me believe you me
if you give if you give Republicans the
house and the Senate and these state
legislators and these Governors they're
going to lean into to criminalizing pot
even more 100 percent
because Joe Biden came out and and and
did the pardon and he's asking them to
change the scheduling they are a hundred
percent gonna lean into making pot
criminalized it's not going to be
successful because they don't understand
how unpopular it really is to
criminalize a plant
they they don't do things based on
popularity they do it based on what they
want and what control they want to have
over you that's fascism
it's why they're fascist
we need to get them the [ __ ] out of our
governments
so we don't they don't have their hands
on policy because they're dumb
[ __ ]
but if you allow
Ed you the voter allow these [ __ ]
fascists to take over
in November of anything
a governorship state legislator the the
House of Representatives the Senate
if you allow them to do that they will
100 percent go the opposite direction
of decriminalizing
marijuana
they're gonna lean into it it ain't
gonna make sense everyone's gonna be
standing around going why the [ __ ] are
they doing that
just like everyone was standing around
wondering why the hell when when they
overturn Roe v Wade these [ __ ] idiots
were leaning into absolutely having no
abortion no exception even the woman's
life
but this is who they are
listen to them
when when Laura Ingraham gets on Fox
News and tells you if you elect
Democrats They're Gonna Give You Porn
and pot as if it's a bad thing listen to
them listen to them
I'm telling you
doubt me they are going to lean into
making pot criminal and it should it
should stay schedule one and we should
give life in prison
Donald Trump has been standing on stage
folks
talking about the death penalty for drug
dealers
hello I'm telling you
I'm telling you
now again the entire country is like
dark Brandon did what
he became dank Brandon
dudes pup pup passing now
that's cool the majority of the country
is for what Joe Biden did he he even
[ __ ] said he was gonna do it
it was a thing he ran on this isn't a
surprise like whoa he did this thing he
said he was gonna do that's what this is
and I don't know about you because I
don't I don't I don't this show is not a
a platform that just Praises Joe Biden
very rarely do I even talk about him
because I am more concentrated in making
your energy and your outrage towards the
fascist that's how you win
is you get people to go vote against a
[ __ ]
but let me tell you something if this
little thing about marijuana
just awakens just a few people
just a small percentage it doesn't have
to be a lot folks
I'm talking about one or two percent
in a state like Texas
think about this if this absolutely
engages in the next few days people to
go you know what maybe this election is
important
just this one little issue
gets one or two percent of people who
weren't going to participate who weren't
going to engage in the midterm
and they engage on this issue in this
issue alone it kind of gets them going
in their brain maybe you know maybe this
ain't such a bad idea maybe I should go
Mark the ballot for the party who is
behind this idea that we shouldn't
[ __ ] criminalize to be putting people
in prison for a plant
if that just just that one little
percentage one or two little percent
Beto can win big time buy four or five
points
we may we may
be able to make sure that Ron Johnson is
sent back in JD Vance Dr Oz
definitely Herschel Walker that lying
piece of [ __ ]
Marco Rubio I don't even know where he's
at but wherever he is send him packing
Blake Masters
an absolutely slam dunk the Senate
if this awakens one or two percent of
people in these states where these house
races are going to be so close because
these Republicans are such [ __ ] Nazis
just one or two percent folks can make
all the difference in the world
all the difference in the world
but it's up to you
to make it that one or two percent pay
attention
and I know it feels like well maybe this
ain't the thing to do but listen
Joe Biden is giving is taking
marijuana off schedule one
and the Republicans are making it
illegal for women to get a medical
procedure to save their lives
which is your choice what do you want do
you want the people who are in charge
who have a [ __ ] brain you have
coupled to reality and logic and common
sense to decriminalize a plant or do you
want the people who are trying to
criminalize
a medical procedure that saves women's
lives which do you want that's your
choice
this isn't complicated
this isn't
and that's the most important thing when
you're talking about this it's not just
the pardons because he he really he
almost has to Pardon these possession
charges with what he wants to do with
rescheduling it because it really would
be a shitty move I would be a horrible
move for a president United States
Joe Biden or anyone else to change the
scheduling of marijuana
and not go back and and pardon
the people who had simple possession at
at a bare minimum it would be really
[ __ ] disingenuous
but you put a decent a decent person in
office who understands these things
and that is and that is the conversation
that you have is look do you want decent
[ __ ] setting policy who
understand logic and rational thought
who don't get this delusional stuff
where they're concentrating on bathrooms
and banning books and trying to take
away a woman's right to her privacy in a
doctor's office and procedures that save
her [ __ ] life or do you want these
dummies you absolutely are not Tethered
to reality they won't shut the [ __ ] up
they worship the orange Mussolini Jesus
they absolutely will buy Hook Line and
sync or anything that [ __ ] says
Any Lies he tells they're [ __ ]
traitors they can't stop talking about
lab tops and and and [ __ ] hookers
when they're the ones who have the
hookers and the laptops they're the ones
charged with [ __ ] tax evasion they're
the ones being investigated
for trying to overthrow the government
of the United States they're the ones
that are being investigated for trying
to cheat and steal elections
they're the ones they're the ones who
are the criminals who do you want in
charge do you want the person who will
take the marijuana off schedule one or
the person who's trying to criminalize a
medical procedure to save a woman's life
simple stuff
simple narratives thank you dank Brandon
but it's up to you to lean into
democracy but let's do this because I
got a lot of democracy to lean into
today I've got some clips I want to show
you the Laurie Ingram clip it's a
uh I think Midas Touch
posted you could just make that into a
an ad like just this clip could be an ad
so let's do this let's round up all the
Tweety tweets and trendy Trends let's go
to the [ __ ] list Roundup start the
countdown
foreign
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
trends of the day
and there's a lot of stuff going on
but the main thing is uh the Dank Brandy
oh I I remember that they're really
harping on dank Brandon for using the
word Armageddon oh they're freaking out
about it I guess he went to a fundraiser
um and the reporters were allowed to
have written uh notes but they were not
allowed to record I guess video or audio
so there's not yet there isn't any
leaked audio or video of of dank Brandon
saying that Putin is absolutely serious
about nuclear weapons I don't disagree
with him here I don't know why
everyone's freaking out
Vladimir Putin is going to lose this war
with Ukraine he is going to be a scared
little animal a caged psychopath a
lunatic he's a murderous dictator he
does not give a [ __ ] about other human
life he absolutely we should take him
seriously when he talks about nuking
other countries
and when you are saying when this
[ __ ] is saying hey you better
let me win a war that I want to win
against a Sovereign Nation and another
democracy because I hate democracy or
I'll nuke the entire world we should
take him seriously and we should be like
nope that's not gonna happen the entire
world should say it's enough of you you
piece of [ __ ] I can't well let me ask
you I can't wait
what about you
I can't wait
for Vladimir Putin to eat an ammo
sandwich how about you how about you
I think ammo sandwiches for all these
tyrants are all around [ __ ] them [ __ ]
them that's what ends up with tyrants
they either they either kill themselves
or they get killed by their people
we know that
this is not going to end well for
Vladimir Putin and I think that's what
Joe Biden is saying like look we're
taking this [ __ ] threat seriously
he's a [ __ ] lunatic he's trying to
destroy democracy all around the world
including ours with Trump and the
Republicans they're all in for Putin if
you don't believe me just go watch a
30-second clip from any Tucker Carlson
show in the last two years and he has
gotten his [ __ ] Putin knee pads on
and it's Russian TV over there on Fox
News full stop having Russian assets and
Russian Spies Like Tulsi gabbardon
continuing this this nonsense about and
even last night talking about how us
giving Aid to Ukraine
actor Vladimir Putin the murderous
dictator has gone in and trying to take
over a Sovereign Nation
has declared war on a Sovereign Nation
killing innocent women and children
committing war crimes
somehow us helping defend Ukraine and
democracy around the world is somehow
Hunter Biden's fault I'm not I'm not
[ __ ] [ __ ] you
you're my favorite turd I would not [ __ ]
you that's literally the [ __ ]
narrative on on Fox news on Decker
Carlson is it's Hunter Biden's fault
and and Joe Biden is part of corruption
in Ukraine and that's what the money is
is it's corruption what are you talking
about Vladimir Putin
ordered his army to go take over Ukraine
any means necessary even war crimes he's
threatening throwing nuclear weapons all
over the place
and these people are on his side
you think you think they're on the side
of democracy I don't [ __ ] think so
what do you think Gabe Sanchez you think
they're on the side of democracy who
Putin or any artist no it seems you seem
a little green over there it's almost
like well you know I uh just you know
it's dank day it's [ __ ] dudes [ __ ]
okay so here's the thing I don't know
[ __ ] about marijuana and I probably
misstated some [ __ ] about how you smoke
and how you I just I don't know I
haven't I haven't heard you I haven't
heard you say anything about it today I
may have said smoke the leaves and that
I don't think that's what oh God that's
what you do it's I mean it's
it's the bud what what what what is it I
I don't I'm not I'm marijuana cannabis
yeah I mean most there's the right
marijuana kind of sewer right well the
right way they just made our audience
you are not because apparently we are
all going to be uh marijuana
connoisseurs now because Fox News says
if you like Democrats that's all you're
going to be doing is pot do they use do
they use the word connoisseur or do they
say that we're gonna be all addicts well
I mean and it connoisseur when it comes
to pot for them and any kind of drug for
them it's all one and the same I mean
I'm not saying I wouldn't eat do the
edible thing right Edibles you got to be
really careful with though cigarette
smoker yeah yeah yeah I can't go down
that road I just yeah uh Edibles you got
yeah you got to be careful with Edibles
because uh too many times I mean I've
done it before and I know a lot of
people
no you wear Edibles no absolutely you
mean yesterday how many times in
celebration I didn't I didn't do it at
all no man oh okay that's that's uh yeah
yeah we'll go for the weekend I've got
other Edibles too that is like in my
fridge that I haven't had that I need to
have that aren't wheat
oh so they're a little different yeah
they're a little different I mean you
know okay what happens yeah it happens
so so tell tell the audience
um about you know since you're our uh
our marijuana expert here because I'm on
the I'm on the the West Coast well I
mean we've got even the green background
yeah yeah yeah yeah well what you're
wondering you're one of these pothead
Elites out there on the coast I'm just
in my Greenhouse here you know just like
cooking up a storm you know
uh okay I don't know [ __ ] about it and I
know that's not the um yeah I know uh
what do you want to know there's well I
mean so tell us about what you think
about this decision from from Joe Biden
number one I I believe that he had to do
the pardons with the rescheduling of it
like that's yeah that's a component he
needed right so it's easy for him to
order the federal government to
reschedule this thing because that's
really what is that's the substance of
this right right but he can't do that
without doing the pardon of at least a
bare minimum of possession uh yeah
because I mean like when you look at it
what's gonna happen here is if you're
like oh well it's he's scheduled you
know it's it's not
you know or we're gonna we're gonna
bring it down then you'd have to like
wait wait what about all these people
who were you know busted for an ounce or
uh you know or or even you know a
smaller amount that they're like boom
you now have a uh you have a felony on
your record and you're going to jail for
the smallest things right these are
things that people get killed over too
um uh depending on what your you know
the color of your skin is
and this is going to be huge not only
for
giving people who have entered the the
prison system a second chance you know
removing those things those those
aspects from the record but also giving
a chance those people to you know live
their life again you know
um and then not only that but also just
the cannibal the the the the Cannabis uh
Market itself
I mean you've seen the effects that have
happened this is these this is the the
path on to decriminalization and uh a
federal
um kind of uh you know legislation that
says okay now it's no longer
illegal you can now have it
recreationally this is we've seen it in
different states they go the medical
route then the recreational route which
we're going to see more in this election
there's certain states exactly I mean
this is going to be a huge this is
definitely a move
it was an October surprise for sure
nobody saw this coming
um you know we've been so kind of in all
of the [ __ ] of like Herschel Walker and
other people but nobody literally nobody
expected this to actually be a
possibility right now
um I think this will be a a nice bump in
the polls for a lot of Democrats showing
because here's the thing the reception
across all voters in a generally
speaking has been pretty positive you've
got you know the left the right you've
got
um
people in the center this is something
that a lot of people either do
recreationally they need medicinally
they also believe this is dumb and
idiotic that we still have a system like
this so archaic and so
um
what costs money it costs a [ __ ] right I
expect I mean to to to put somebody in
jail for the smallest thing right the
smallest thing
and then ruin their life but not only
that but then it's like great now we add
on taxpayer money to pay for certain
expenditures to cover the cost of
another person in the prison system that
shouldn't have been there in the first
place well a lot of municipalities have
even figured this out throughout the
years where they would actually the
municipalities started to say we're
tired of having these [ __ ] court
systems locked up for possession like in
these college towns mainly like this is
ridiculous we have we have dockets that
are dozens long every week that we have
to go through and they figured out hey
they just instructed their local law
enforcement officials like just write
them a goddamn traffic ticket right a
[ __ ] traffic ticket for a possession
over a you know a certain ounce and less
and just move the hell on it's it's it's
costing us too much time and money to
try to bring these cases into a
courtroom it's ridiculous yeah just the
same way as like uh if you wrote
criminal tickets for jaywalking all day
long like what in the [ __ ] are you doing
it's just too much money and too much
time right
it's it's going to be something like I
said that's going to begin to move us
down this this path of great you know
more businesses
um that will enter into the Cannabis bit
into the market the industry uh more
opportunity for people I mean
I will say the tax system for
recreational use like in California they
it was prop 64 they passed
um in 2000
16 2017 I very much one and that was
supposed to be the thing that was going
to be like great we've got recreational
we're going to make it more affordable
this is going to be great we could do
different things and
and then what they ended up doing was
they added a 30 tax which is a deterrent
for people who say well then what's the
difference between me getting either my
card or getting me getting it from
someone else either a friend who has a
card or buying it through you know the
black market in that sense of like not
through a regular regulated
you know store let's say and because of
that it the taxes that are put on there
so like if I were to go in and buy a
hundred dollars worth of you know
cannabis products and uh I would have to
pay 130 right which is insane that I
have to pay that much of a markup for
recreational use so there are certain
places that still need to work on the
legislation that are there
um
well but don't you think that this gives
these states the rights it's funny how
the states rights party is going to be
against us um this gives the states the
rights and the in the ability and the
work room to really make sure that
whatever whatever
you know opioid Market that they have
the Cannabis Market that they have that
they can control it they can tax it
properly right they can regulate it
properly and make sure that it's safe
and also deliver a product that's good
for the consumer again whether it's
recreational use or medical use uh Jay
brings up a good point because I think
this is
also a thing that um
that is going to advance in our country
is that
and Joe Biden brought it up in his
statement that the actual use of this
drug marijuana
proportionately
between white and people of color is
almost exactly the same
there's not much difference in the
overall use of it
but the actual criminal prosecution and
the actual sentences that come with the
criminal prosecution
are much heavier on people of color Yes
and that I think is is one thing that
you're going to see the right season
what I mean by that is they're going to
say some racist ass [ __ ] about your
pardoning
Thugs and crit you know it's going to be
code word
it's gonna be code word yeah
um and they're gonna play into that so
you're gonna hear this a lot
um because that is the fear that they're
gonna try to use here because people
aren't scared of marijuana they're just
not
but these trumped up white people it's
really easy to scare them with the the
black people talk right and that's what
Fox News that's what this Laura Ingraham
clip is kind of all about
um people she I haven't seen the clip
but I can only imagine she definitely
loves to go on the Reefer Madness I mean
so does anyone else on Fox news they had
Reaper Madness on her show like several
months ago right right like had the that
was that well she didn't call read for
madness I I think I I was one of the
people that was like oh here we go read
for madness we're going through like the
1950s [ __ ] because what she was calling
it was pot psychosis oh and that's the
way it's like well part psychosis leads
to people committing crimes murder all
these different things which is like
that's not at all hey tell me one person
who has ever gotten high and said oh man
you know what I should do right now I
should go commit a crime never in my
life like I said earlier maybe stealing
a bag of Funyuns maybe that maybe you
know never in my life have I smoked had
an edible anything like that where I've
where I have not been either with
friends at a park on my couch in my
apartment whatever where I go oh [ __ ] I
had have this sudden rage to go commit a
crime never I can barely even think to
the extent of
what what what should I have to eat
right or like what should I you know or
like oh [ __ ] I'm gonna go take a nap
right which are some of the best I don't
know well uh Amanda points out a good
point here it all hits different if you
don't know the difference in Edibles
joints pens dabs I mean I remember I
remember uh one of the first times I did
uh a dab straight off a hot plate
um with a little burner and I took at
the time wait wait say that all again
because I I so there's so adapt you can
have a wax which is a more concentrated
form right and there's like a little
metal hot plate right so you use a
little burner one of those like you know
like little burner you know the burner
that some people were like oh I got this
like little souffle and they like burn
you know or like whatever the [ __ ]
they're making
uh it's uh I did it at a friend's house
and I it's a concentrated out of friends
yeah I did it before and so what that
hot plate sitting back there on that
dresser no no no don't don't look back
there uh what what ended up happening
was uh I didn't know the difference
right so my friend was like oh you
should have this it's much better
and I took
inhale like I would out of a bong
and I sounds like you have no experience
at this by the way at the at the first
time the first time I did it I just I
just moved to San Francisco I was with a
co-worker you know he was like oh you
should try this and I was like great
okay cool did it and then everyone in
the room that I was with were like oh
and we're supposed to go out and they're
like oh [ __ ] and I was like what and
they're like uh I mean good on you for
taking a hit that big but you're [ __ ]
and I was like what do you mean he goes
just just if you don't want to go out
tonight that's totally fine if you do
whatever
we ended up going out and I was like
[ __ ] man I was so [ __ ] up like so
[ __ ] high the rest of the night it
was crazy but I just remember audience
can you imagine Gabe Sanchez being high
I can't imagine that so so [ __ ] up but
my it was just funny because in the
moment my friend my friend just like oh
and I was like what are you what are you
talking about he's like yeah that's
gonna that's gonna hit different it
reminds me of the scene in um Cheech and
Chong when they're in the car and he
tells them to take a certain pill and
he's like
oh you just took the most the most I've
ever seen anyone take is that the is
that the moment is that your yeah
that's pretty pretty much that's what
happened yeah yeah uh I mean it was it
was great I mean I had a fun time uh but
it was definitely a learning experience
to be like oh next time I should know
when I'm dealing with more concentrated
forms little wax dab you know
so when when someone offers you a dab
and it has to do with marijuana you
should be careful is that what you're
saying I mean typically yeah I mean I
don't know it depends on what your
challenge is well I mean maybe maybe it
could be I could look I'm not Willie
Nelson or or Snoop Dogg level which is
like I don't know if you've ever heard
the story of uh he made an appearance on
Mythic quest which is uh Snoop Dogg yeah
yeah it's a it's an Apple TV show with
uh one of the creators Rob one of the
creators from always sunny and Snoop
Dogg rolled up and it was like seven in
the morning and he showed up to the set
and he was like Hey Snoop wants you to
come on the trailer and he's like all
right cool so he like shows up to his
bus and snoops like got joints ready and
they you know and it's like you know a
snoop a stoop joint which is [ __ ]
potent and they both smoke
and uh he said the rest of the day he
was incredibly High he's like luckily I
only had one scene that I had to film
where I was like walking past Snoop Dogg
but he's like the rest of the day I had
a bunch of calls with the Apple Finance
team to be budgeting and he was like he
he did it and he's like I gotta go I
gotta go I can't do this right now yeah
oh my god well here's here's Laura Nazi
Ingraham
um telling us if we elect Democrats that
we're gonna have a really good time I'm
not sure why she thinks these are all
bad things but let's listen here to
dummy this is what they're going to give
you more of if you elect them
okay abortion pot porn and more January
6 hearings
great how is this I don't are they
you're you're giving me a pamphlet of
hey welcome to Disney World you wanna
you wanna come in all right I don't
understand porn is already legal right
right it literally the Internet is just
porn so that's what caused the internet
to become popular right yeah also also
you can thank any advance that we've
made in in technology DVDs HD 4K all of
those things were on the Forefront
because of porn the porn industry alone
have pushed those Technologies so if
you've got [ __ ] Blu-ray you got 4K
and you got all these things you can
take the porn industry for those okay
because if it wasn't for them you'd be
[ __ ] still on VHS or [ __ ] betamax
or some [ __ ] betamax oh [ __ ] you'd
be putting the reels on the [ __ ]
projector right so you can think porn
for the way that you watch uh your
movies these days yeah and you know who
doesn't like some some porno know even
yeah weird porno because it can get
weird speaking of weirdos this guy
probably watches a different type of
porn if you know what I mean this is a
republican from I don't know he's a
Libertarian excuse me he's even worse
than a republican
also even Libertarians have have been a
positively receiving the news about
Biden's well yeah of course
well yeah but here's here's this
he claims to be a libertarian
but he's talking about he's talking
about referendums speaking of
referendums and Most states have
referendums on this pot issue
referendums right referendums but this
is
this is a referendum that he wants to
have and he pulls it out of nowhere here
about what the age of consent is it is
really [ __ ] weird coming from a guy
who looks like this this age who is the
number one referendum he wants to talk
about is consent
this is who these [ __ ] idiots are but
let's listen that should be up for a
vote what should the age of consent be
this is something that reasonable Minds
disagree on that should be up for a vote
I'm dead serious why why what do you
mean reasonable my what the [ __ ] is he
talking about
this is this is Arizona how is that
another debate
this libertarian candidate says that
they should have a referendum on the age
of consent for statutory rape
uh I'm telling you man I'm telling you
I'm telling you these people are Super
Hyper focused on this stuff and the
reason why is because it's all they
think about
it is weird [ __ ] it's weird stuff I wish
we didn't have to talk about this
nonsense if there are people running for
public office
that want to have referendums in States
because they think they'll get here's
what he's I I I can tell what he's
saying he's saying let's have a
referendum because they won't the
legislator won't lower the consent age
but surely the masses will right like
what the [ __ ] are you talking about
this is I mean this is was it Tennessee
that I mean it eventually was well it
was Tennessee who who who who tried to
float the bill that would let's just
open it up well I mean what they were
trying to do was have a different type
of legal marriage marriage right right
and then by in that bill they were
hiding the fact that they were not
setting an age for consent for that new
type of marriage right so their dumb
asses could go out and marry young but
they eventually reloaded the other day
right right
once it got pointed out right right once
it got pointed out that they were like
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa so you're
wanting to marry children like
um new don't right it's hard to it's
hard to Rebrand when you say let's lower
the age it's very hard to Rebrand from
so you're trying to marry kids and
you're like what no well you know and
then of course because it is their own
projection it's the same group the
Republicans who want to be the ones who
say well these people are being
pedophiles and they want to marry kids
and they want to have sex with them and
[ __ ] and it's like no that's actually
you you guys are the ones trying to
lower the age you guys want to make it a
Justified excuse to say I can marry this
14 12 year old girl whatever it might be
you're [ __ ] creep man it's weird it's
weird look
Democrats want to watch want to watch
porn get high and make sure people are
held accountable and make sure women
have privacy in their doctor's office
Republicans and magla Republicans and
Maga Libertarians for that matter yeah
because that's really that's really
where the Maga Republicans come from is
this libertarian [ __ ] and let's be let's
be clear the age of consent is 18 when
you're an adult it should be that it
should not be lower I don't know how
Gabe fake Gabe oh my God the [ __ ]
dumbest is this guy is this guy no
well he he's assuming that we're saying
that it should be lower than 18 we're
calling this dude out and everyone else
who wants to lower the age below 18. so
Gabe again
the whole
ability to comprehend is a bit difficult
it seems like but if you listen if you
just just stop and listen then you'll
understand that what we said was this
guy's a [ __ ] creep
and it should not be lower than the age
of 18.
okay so I'm gonna I want to show you a
clip here of something that
um who found this it wasn't Ron yes it
was Ron
little cowski this is a video of uh
Stuart Stu Peter's Network apparently
um
see if because we're gonna go to
bonehead but no better setup here than
these boneheads
um I don't know who these [ __ ] idiots
are I have no idea but there are people
that are gonna vote that are listening
to this [ __ ] like fake Gabe fake gate
probably believes everything in this
video I'm sure if they gave voted early
he mailed his ballot in and he already
right he's already mailed his fraudulent
mail-in ballad he probably wrote in
Trump honestly right he probably did
he's probably gonna say County you're
not going to play the whole clip
um because I can't stand to listen to
all this nonsense listen to what these
[ __ ] are saying about the
hurricane Ian listen this is I mean this
is not surprising
but there are people like fake Gabe who
believe this [ __ ] just because oh well
Trump says it and Trump supporters say
it's that must be true let's listen to
Florida the governor Ronda Santos has
not been complying with vaccine he's not
been complying with this climate change
agenda that the rest of the deep State
and Shadow government has been going
along with and pushing he's not been
complying with the sanctuary State
illegal immigrants Florida is booming
it's successful so many people have been
moving there and you know the economy
has boomed they didn't shut down during
covet and of course it's right before a
major election too one month away it
just seems to me that oh what better way
to bring Florida to its knees this
booming economy this booming State let's
bring it to its knees with a hurricane
is it possible first of all for them to
do that and secondly I want to know what
makes this hurricane in your eyes what
are sort of the Hallmarks of a
manufactured hurricane
did she just say and I and I I watched
this a couple times and I I when you
hear this
whoever this other [ __ ] is speak she is
literally saying this is what she's
saying that the left the Liberals
manufactured a hurricane now I am not
saying that it's some kind of
like
um you know it's all staged in Hollywood
and Ron DeSantis is going to the stage
set where it's the destructions
but what she's saying is is that this is
like a false flag hurricane type thing I
can't what in the actual [ __ ] are these
people talking about
it it
I'm dead serious it sounds okay
it certainly sounds like she is talking
about how this was manufactured by the
left
because because Florida was doing so
great business was booming people were
great didn't have the vaccines
whatever [ __ ] [ __ ]
so someone on the left has a hurricane
maker like [ __ ] throw some [ __ ] in a
Ninja blender and you're good like that
like I don't even understand is it the
same answer
lasers I don't know it's probably
I mean probably they're probably
shooting you know again this sounds like
the plot of like a double07 movie which
I'm pretty sure they've already done
recently in the last few years which is
basically weather control you've got a
weather machine satellite up in space
and it causes this area to to change the
weather patterns do you think that's
what manipulated they've seen the movie
they see I think when they're like I
think so
these are the same these are the same
people that thought that that God I
can't believe you're gonna have to say
this again these are the same people
that originally thought Biden and Trump
did a Face-Off movie plot scenario like
literally took the face off one person
put it on the other as if the body
shapes would ever make sense
and then tried to say that if if Biden
if when they sh when they see Trump in
jail it's really Biden in jail and when
they see uh Biden in the office at the
at the White House it's actually Trump
in the what in the white house as
president that's the dumb ass [ __ ] that
people were saying online that is a real
thing there was a Face-Off theory that a
bunch of cute people were pushing around
on top of
well this interpretation of the
Constitution and this this date was
really in March and not April and this
and that blah blah blah all trying to
justify Trump being able to come back
and become president again
these are the same people I mean then
again I mean you have to remember Trump
was the one who asked if we could nuke a
hurricane
well I mean that's not surprising either
that they're freaking out over Biden
saying take take it seriously when Putin
says he'll use nuclear weapons
Joe Biden says yesterday take I take
Putin seriously when he talks about
using nuclear weapons and in this and
the people like oh my god did you hear
this Joe Madden's gonna get us into
nuclear war and like your guy was
talking about nuking hurricanes using
nuclear weapons on hurricanes and he was
serious about it and everyone in the
room's like no that's not that's and
then after he tweeted that the hurricane
was going to go and ravage Alabama he
goes Sharpie and then he draws in
Alabama right that is the guy
thankfully that is no longer in control
of one the nuclear codes though he did
try to steal them right or at least had
some documents that had information on
there but also the fact that this is you
know thankfully this is the guy that's
not in the office making the decisions
of hey so how do we uh disperse disaster
relief how do we help these people out
how do we make sure that Americans have
shelter food water and and what have you
so they're able to uh get back up and
and start their lives back over after
their lives have been totally displaced
by this natural disaster natural I'm
gonna say again natural disaster not
man-made not man-made and for fake gape
here saying it's a false flag that
climate change is the cause of the end
okay can we not go back to Ron DeSantis
literally being like this is a 500 year
event this is a serious thing we've got
to take it seriously we need research
dude your dude said your guy said that
so fake Gabe do you believe what these
boneheads are saying because here's the
thing I'm going to play you a little bit
of this guy's explanation
of how the left is mainly don't play the
full clip Tony well I feel like that's
not gonna help you oh listen to this guy
listen to this guy just puke up all
kinds of weather words and it sounds
really cool and I'm sure fate Gabe will
believe it by the time he's done
you can say definitively that storm
hurricane Ian was absolutely positively
steered period we recorded the
animations of ground-based radio
frequency microwave Transmissions I
challenge your listeners to just look at
what we have captured on the homepage of
geogreenwatch.org controlling hurricane
Ian I think you've seen that film Deanna
right yes absolutely everybody should
watch it
so what that shows is that the
ground-based transmissions and these are
patented technologies that have been in
existence for decades when you activate
those ground-based transmitters with an
air mass that's saturated with
electrically conductive particles that
are being sprayed from climate
engineering jet aircraft you manipulate
those particles if you manipulate the
particles you manipulate the air mass
okay I can't I can't anymore I can't
with it listen these are the the people
who believe this garbage are the same
people who watch what late night
infomercials you know the ones with the
electric pads the shock pads that you
put on your your stomach and it creates
ABS yeah yeah they're the same
[ __ ] that believe that [ __ ]
this is the same people these are the
same people that believe like kellyanne
Conway thinking that microwaves uh that
turn into cameras in our spying on you
uh you know and Trump believing that
like these are the same people that are
[ __ ] look if we send a bunch of
electric particles out of this machine
and we block where the [ __ ] are these
machines is it from space
is it in the ocean I how is this [ __ ] I
this guy is literally saying that we had
machines that were manipulating a
natural disaster and saying this is the
path it's going to take and instead of
taking this other path we do we
basically kind of added a buffer to it
and we shoved it up this way you know
there's a movie from the 90s called
twister do you remember this movie oh
dude I love twister right right and it
and it has the the Dorothy the little
like the I don't know it looks like an
oversized crock pot in the back of a
pickup truck right yeah yeah and then
they try to send these little things
tornado and [ __ ] yeah and then they cut
the Pepsi cans out to have wings on it
because they figure out well they're not
really flying around in the in the
tornado right and they and they do it
now I've never watched that movie like
oh my God this could be really good
science now there may be something to it
but this guy this guy is a [ __ ] idiot
when he absolutely is saying out loud
because she's like oh it's manufacturer
but he's like no no no they were
steering it they were steering it to to
hurt Ron DeSantis yeah you people are
[ __ ] ridiculous this is
um
and if you ever want to know how
Relentless they are to win and take
power to take away your rights and your
[ __ ] Freedom this is the links they
are willing to go to
to convince people that the left steers
manufactured hurricanes towards the
state to hurt a [ __ ] Republican this
is really stupid dumb [ __ ]
uh to valorate yes this guy does he's
definitely on the level of Mike Lindell
I'm gonna I'm gonna subpoena all the
machines
so maybe he this guy's gonna go after
the weather machines that are just out
there in the open sending electric
particles that are manipulating the path
that a natural disaster was taking like
hurricane Ian to say oh you know what we
need to go 10 degrees more Southwest up
to the corner of for like what the [ __ ]
are we what are you what are you saying
well he says all kinds of weather words
you know I he said weather words in
there so it sounds like he knows you
know what he's talking about that's why
that's really dumb people look at this
go hey this guy's really smart he knows
all these weather words he must know
stuff about hurricanes and right and
what he's showing I don't know if that's
a it was a thermal map of the storm or
what exactly I mean it looked like kind
of a hot to cold thermal reading I don't
know I'm not a it's immediately
absolutely
proves that the left was steering it
though for sure it's pretty convincing
to me that uh the left is in fact the
ones that are you know using that Soros
money to build that weather machine and
it's like it's almost as if they think
that this is like a drone they're like
okay and we're gonna go this way and
this like it's they just plugged in
their phone and like great I got my
drone and we're gonna we're gonna cause
this hurricane to shift course away from
this area we're gonna cause more damage
over here less damage over there
that makes no sense I know why why would
why would we oh my God why wouldn't we
steer it out into the ocean so there was
no damage at all right I mean I'm all
for steering hurricanes away from places
that would cause damage that's cool if
we can figure out if we can get together
with this dumb [ __ ] and figure out what
he's saying is true which is not but if
we could man it would make a great
partnership to steer these things away
from places of property and people and
communities and economies
not only that but if if let's say the
Democrats were in fact in some weird ass
Bizarro weather-controlling world and
they directed it towards Florida
and let's assume this is a blue versus
red thing right wouldn't you assume that
the Democrats who are controlling this
weather from a weather machine would say
oh [ __ ] Florida and do the whole [ __ ]
state or just the right side I mean
really right this is the same nonsense
they're like oh they're cheating in the
election like real if we were gonna
cheat [ __ ] we'd have took way
more seats in the Senate way more seats
in the House and we'd have slam dunked
your guys's ass into Oblivion yeah what
the hell are you talking about this is
all nonsense these are boneheads
speaking of boneheads speaking of monons
we have bone end of the week now welcome
to Stone TV Jersey is it stoned maybe
Stone team I don't know
um but we have bone of the week coming
up after this break I have a special uh
commercial in this break I want to play
uh the trucker Convoy because this is
the same group of people the same is
same [ __ ] that believe this
[ __ ] is steering tornadoes the same
people thought they could shut down the
economy by driving around Washington
scared of rain everyone stick around
we'll be right back with bone end of the
week right after these messages
oh
what the [ __ ] is wrong with you people
it's a rhetorical question at best
we'll be right back on the Tony Michaels
podcast
[Music]
letters from the trucker Convoy
there's Tammy by the time we reach DC
White was 50 strong in number some
patriots ran out of gas along the way
we got plenty of Slim Jims skull
near run out of Natty light
hope it don't rain tomorrow so we can
Circle the city again years
Bob
dear Bob I'm fixing to send you some
more of them Doritos you like the red
bag not the live love and blue one
in your absence I discovered a rash on
my neck and no it ain't no hickey and I
even seen my cousin Brody in ages
stay strong wipe your ass at least once
a day
here's Tammy
we're back to the Tony Michaels podcast
welcome back to the show
in about 30 minutes
[Music]
in about 30 minutes to do
bonehead of the week
boy do we have some great bonehead three
women talking about all week
so let's get into it for bone end of the
week Gabe
there were so many boneheads this week
oh you changed your you changed your
color there yeah yeah yeah different
different segment different segments to
go to the other colors I still got the
dark branding back here or the Dank
Brandon yeah what do you think about the
Dank Brandon I'm still waiting on the
file by the way for the day Brandon
merch
okay yes we got Brandon merch coming
just waiting on the file so I can make
the shirt post it right and then we can
make the graphic here so if we get this
in this next 30 minutes
I will give you the Dank Brandon merch
well let's do this since we got a lot of
boneheads to get to and not a lot of
time let's start the music
[Music]
[Applause]
welcome to this edition of bonehead of
the week Gabe we got a lot of boneheads
going on but I want to explain to the
audience
how bonehead of the week works you vote
you decide who is the bonehead of the
week and me and my co-host Gabe Sanchez
break it down on the Tony Michaels
podcast every single Friday every one of
them here on the Tony Michaels podcast
live where you can watch the replay on
the Midas touch Network every single
Friday evening
and if you're watching on the Mindless
touch Network please subscribe now but
also if you're on the mind of touch
Network or here on the Tony Michaels
podcast make sure to subscribe to our
channel the Tony Michaels podcast it's
important because you can vote there
Gabe that's where you cast your ballot
for bonehead of the week is YouTube you
also can go over to Twitter and follow
at Tony Michaels pod you can cast your
ballot for bonehead of the week there
every single week and don't forget to
download every single episode of the
Tony Michaels podcast but we also post
the bonehead of the week every Sunday
for you to download Apple's modify
Google make sure to follow And subscribe
and leave us a great review on the
podcast directory of your choice while
you're there okay we got we got we got
boneheads of the boneheads of the
boneheads this week we have boneheads
whoosh Kanye West Herschel Walker and
Matt Walsh I noticed they all all their
names start with w
I don't think that was planned that was
nice
Walker and Walsh yeah three dubs www
yeah we should have www a little more
bonehead yes oh yeah well I know I mean
that's as they say that's how the cookie
crumbles you know how the cookie crumble
so let's let's start
um
Matt Walsh and Kanye West holy [ __ ] this
kind of stuff is just
um infuriating but let's start with Matt
Walsh for a second here because I want
to I want to explain exactly what Matt
Walsh did but there's also a clip of it
that I'll play
but what we get from the Met Walsh
bone-headed moment this week is that he
basically admits that he wants to be
able to impregnate teenage girls so he
can trap them in marriages am I getting
that right sounds about right you know
he as we'll see in the clip he talks
about how 1957 was the peak was the peak
year that girls were having babies you
know these teenagers were having babies
and then he and his whoever is a guest
on the show or co-host I don't know
because I don't listen to [ __ ]
cuck radio but uh on the show they talk
about why that was a thing and how
they're trying to justify
uh kind of why that's okay
why their own secret sick weird
fantasies desires are okay to have
because that's how it used to be I love
Hassan biker nasan ABI let's take on oh
it was fantastic yeah spot on he said he
says shocked that Matt Walsh is
interested in pregnating 16 year olds
totally shocked like this isn't a
surprise that Matt Walsh would say this
garbage yeah but here here's the clip
we'll listen to a bit of it now he's
talking I'm not sure who he's talking to
here on [ __ ] radio but he's got his
co-host or his guest or something and
they're just as vile and disgusting as
he is but let's listen to the the pedos
have their pedo talk none it is not in
fact ever since the beginning of time
teenage girls have been getting pregnant
it used to be more common the peak ever
since they started keeping records of
these things which they only started
doing recently like in the 20th century
um but ever since they started keeping
records in 1957 was the peak for teenage
pregnancy 1957.
this is not the flex that he thinks it
is yeah it really is not it's very gross
she's like since the dawn of time people
have been raping teenage girls and
getting them pregnant so now we should
have the ability like what the [ __ ] are
you talking about or it's like since the
dawn of time we've had women that have
been felt or or forced into a
relationship and marriage and their role
has been dictated to them that it's only
to make me a meal and make me a baby
and that's what that's what Matt Walsh
and whoever the [ __ ] guest is on this
show are trying to use right now they're
trying to be like well it worked back
then so we should make it work now right
well you know this is coming from a guy
who doesn't know what a woman is yeah
like literally he doesn't know what a
man is either literally literally his
called
what is a woman like he does no he
doesn't he I think around the country
trying to figure out what a woman was I
think honestly there was a bit of
projection going on here so he was
projecting his own kind of well what is
a woman right like I don't really know I
mean we know Ben Shapiro can't get his
wife wet we know uh who owns the daily
wire who is right it's all connected
radio [ __ ] exactly and so this is just
one of those moments where I feel like
there's a subliminal side to him asking
he's like no but really I don't know
like I want to know because I don't I
don't understand as Matt Walsh would say
I don't understand I don't respect women
I want them to be my 16 year old sex
slave in my basement like that's the
type of guy that Matt Walsh comes off as
and I'm not gonna play the rest the
other two minutes of this clip because
it just continues on with this vile
garbage about how they think it's their
right as a white man to impregnate
teenage girls so that way they can trap
them into marriages for decades and
decades and decades to come and I'm sure
fake gay in the chat will say oh you're
taking it totally out of context you're
not playing the whole clip where they
talk about marrying teenage girls yeah
okay okay we'll we'll go with that
narrative so let's move on to the next
bonehead because I'm sure next week and
the week after Matt Walsh will continue
to do bone-headed [ __ ]
as well as the next bonehead Kanye West
Kanye West
um
did some really weird stuff over the
last couple weeks he actually um
he went to some fashion show and I'm not
sure
I don't know what fashion show it is
it's not here in the United States it's
somewhere do you know where this fashion
show was Gabe I'm not really it was uh
was it in Paris I think it was yeah he
appeared with Candace Owens which
Candace Owens is the Herschel Walker of
Kanye West right yeah I mean like these
are all one in the same of what these
kind of people what I'll say is that uh
uh yes one it was in Paris
um uh if I'm but he was there with
Candace Owens I'm like yeah yeah yeah
yeah it was there yeah yeah because yeah
the reason he was in Paris was because
11 years ago he had his first fashion
show there so he did another one now
he's with Candace and he wears a shirt
that says white lives matter right
Christian Walker is one I mean you know
Christian Walker is very much on the
same path that uh Candace Owens is on
um and Kanye West now I don't know what
to what degree each of them truly
believe what they're spewing and what
they're saying in terms of white
supremacist rhetoric or anti
um you know person of color rhetoric but
the fact that you're gonna wear a shirt
white lives matter he was on Tucker
Carlson last night
this type of this type of Tanya Harding
he talks about the clintons In that clip
he talks about white lives matter he
talks about being trying to be
manipulated by the left like it's all of
these things I mean you have to also
remember that Kanye West does uh he he
uh does have bipolar
um we know that you know he I don't know
if he currently takes medication for it
but he he did have a moment this past
year where he was like in his Wyoming
home and it wasn't seen people and you
know was separated from his family and
that caused issues so there was a little
bit of that in like the mental health
side which is unfortunate for anyone who
has that but you know some of the stuff
that he says I do Wonder like is it
truly him believing this or is it the
fact that you know he doesn't take his
doesn't take medication right or is it
like I don't know is it a bunch of
paranoia that he has
um or is it truly what he believes
um or does he live in this like
heightened state of reality right now so
I saw a Tic Tac
um yesterday as I was scrolling through
Tick Tock and this game
I don't even know who it is the guy on
tic tac's like wait so you're telling me
a bunch of Backwoods rednecks are now
Kanye West fans is that what you're
saying just because he's willing to
dissent to them this is really weird
it's weird stuff right weird stuff like
they they hate they hate rap music and
all that noise but they love them some
Kanye West because he's willing to set
for them well it also gives them an
excuse to say the n-word without having
any sort of issue
yeah right but I mean this this clip
here of Kanye
um and the Tanya Harding stuff but
really um the other clip I want to show
too is just the the one clip where he's
talking his explanation of why
he
um loves or why he wore the White lives
matter is one reason and then the look
just the pure look that Tucker Carlson
oh yeah is is but let me play that Tonya
Harding part first can you find me the
one where he Tucker Carlson just gazes
upon him like he originally ask him to
um
do something retain his teeth I'm just
gonna say this whole segment really had
uh Clayton Bixby Vibes going on right
for anyone who remembers Dave Chappelle
the first right pilot episode right what
they were like [ __ ] it we're going for
it and uh right yeah I'm getting out of
this yeah well well here is here's Kanye
describing how him wearing white lives
matter was like Tonya Harding I I can't
figure this out but let's try to
decipher it and for the people even if
you don't believe in God God believes in
you
so you made reference to the White lives
matter t-shirt which you brought out at
Paris Fashion Week why did you do that
and what did it mean
you know
I did I do certain things from a feeling
I like I just I just channeled the
energy it just feels right
it's using
a gut instinct a connection with God
and
just Brilliance you know like it's if
you ask like Tonya Harding how
she did the the triple flip or the
triple spin she was in so much practice
that when it was time for her to skate
in a in a competitive format it just
happened like it happened outside of
practice that happened in the real
format are you catching why this has
anything to do with a t-shirt that says
white lives matter on are you catching
this no I don't I can't I can't figure
this out I I watched this a couple of
times to try to figure out what the hell
he's talking about here like what the
hell does Tanya Harding have to do
uh it's I I can't I because he knows who
Tanya Harding is Right does he I would
assume I feel like Tonya Harding is so
ingrained within like the Lexicon of of
our
our country that you everyone be like oh
pulled a Tanya Harding like everyone
knows who she was your figure skater
what she did uh you know
break the knees or break the leg uh but
there was even a movie that came out
just like two years ago uh but maybe
that's where his brain is going I don't
I can't figure out what the hell this
has to do with the the T-shirt I can't
figure it out what it has to do with the
idea he even goes on to say in one part
about his dad texting him uh his dad was
a a former founding member of the Black
Panthers in Chicago I think he says
um which again I I take him at his word
for that
um but how his dad thought this was
funny too or something
um I don't I don't get I mean like I
know sorry I'm trying to find the clip I
know the one you're talking about
because basically he says like why did
you wear and he goes well because White
lives do matter right right and then
Tucker and and it's it's really the
response
that the the look on Tucker Carlson's
face that's yeah very telling when when
he when he does that I'm trying to
figure out who had that clip did Asian
or Aaron have that clip I thought I
retweeted it I don't know maybe I did
maybe I didn't I think I've got uh it's
a two-minute Club but I think it's oh
here it is here it is okay you got it
cat had it can't okay
um she says uh oh here we go
ah get someone to look at you like
Tucker looks at Connie after he says
white lives matter watch
what's Tucker Carlson it it almost feels
like his his ball Tanner heats up when
oh yeah I'm assuming he is I'm assuming
that he wears a ball tanning belt that
it's like a chastity belt but it
constantly has a ball Tanner on so yeah
yeah there's a there's a constant uh
glowing that comes out of his uh nether
regions right but but the look on his
face it feels like it it the the degree
on the Tanner that he has on the ball
Tanner hand on goes up like a thousand
degrees watch it oh yeah this this is
this is kind of weird so the answer to
why I wrote White lives matter on a
shirt is because they do
it's the obvious thing yeah so
let me let me give you a briefly this is
this is oh [ __ ] yeah yeah like oh yeah
yeah of course yeah oh yeah everyone
everyone has always known this you don't
have to put it on a t-shirt anywhere for
people to know this the reason why the
reason why people say black lives matter
is because to people like Tucker Carlson
they don't know that yeah they don't
know that and it's a thing you have to
say because people there are still
people running around who don't think
they do
okay you [ __ ] boneheads especially
Kanye West
and it and it really is you know
it really is rich
that someone like gagne who who would
suffer no Financial consequences from
this because he's not gonna lose his
well-being or his [ __ ] money or the
money that he's gained over time he's
not gonna go broke because of this
it is really rich for him to do this
right and to basically spit all over his
fans there's also a great clip out there
if you can find it and I'll play it uh
and I don't know who it is but just
railing him for his support of trump and
it's the same [ __ ] here yeah it's the
exact same [ __ ] that's here
um where Tucker Carlson is gazing upon
look at him gazing look on oh [ __ ]
Tucker just loves the the Tucker o face
that's coming I mean that's showing
himself uh in in this video and also
like what faces he was making when we
didn't see it on his angle I can only
imagine as soon as he was like well of
course White lives matter you know he's
like of course of course he's like oh
[ __ ] yes someone someone who isn't white
said it this is amazing he just said it
on [ __ ] TV we got it right are you
recording oh my God this is amazing like
now anytime somebody says black lives
matter I can show him a clip of Kanye a
black man who was successful saying
White lives matter do matter because
that's the obvious choice
that is what Tucker's going to do he's
probably going to fight I guarantee
Tucker goes home and just [ __ ] plays
that clip over and over and he goes
white lives do matter of course White
lives do matter of course White lives do
matter of course meanwhile
uh Tucker Carlson's wife is like hey you
coming to bed he goes yeah just one one
more minute just give me one minute in
the bathroom here's here's the clip I
was talking about oh when he when he
showed the TMZ
and the reason why I feel like that
because Kanye you're entitled to your
opinion you're entitled to believe
whatever you want but there is fact and
real world real life consequence behind
everything that you just said and while
you are making music and being an artist
and he goes on to say it now this is a
TMZ clip so this is going to be this is
at the TMZ office I was here in La so
Kanye showed up to the office
and I can't remember if the event was
they were talking about Kanye and then
he showed up because he was like all
right let's talk about this or he was
near and he just showed up I forget the
order of events but he was there and
that is one of their other like just
like because the way that the setup in
TMZ is everyone is like uh they're
pitching ideas and they're talking so
it's kind of you you you learn about
everyone in the office so that was just
another employee at TMZ who addresses
because I think the comment was in
response to saying that slavery was a
choice if I remember correctly it was
when Kanye said slavery's a choice and
everyone's like you you're telling me
that for 400 years they chose to be in
that position but it's the same dumb
[ __ ] where he supported Trump and now
he's doing the White lives matter with
Candace Owens it's the same it's the
same dumb [ __ ] at where they're they're
ignoring ignoring what is fact and what
is reality uh because they're spitting
on black lives matter right because
there was no white lives matter movement
why I mean they didn't there was they
just didn't call themselves White lives
matter they called themselves like the
Ku Klux Klan the neo-nazis and there's
plenty of White lives matter movements
but they didn't say the words White
lives matter until we had to actually
tell the country hey black lives do
matter right and it was a movement and
also all lives can't matter right until
we actually include
other lives that are not white and
that's the point of the movement the
entirety yeah but they don't get there
right like I've got videos on YouTube of
making a sketch that was a basic basic
analogy which is like hey somebody hurt
themselves great do you need a Band-Aid
oh I why can't I get the Band-Aid right
now well we're trying to help this other
one this other person who has a more
serious wound
and then like oh well this is all
Band-Aids you know it's like that type
of [ __ ] where they are getting upset
at the fact that the that them as a
white group collectively white people
are not getting the attention that they
normally get because God forbid we have
equality in this country right God
forbid we give everyone equality and
equity in say in representation because
if we don't then the white man the white
person the the the oppressed group now
as they like to call themselves are
butthurt and they feel neglected and
ignored and uh and because we want to
give everyone the attention that they
need and everyone the the resources and
Aid that they need
uh white people get really upset right
especially rich white people rich white
people like uh maybe our dishonorable
mention oh
how did he make delicious I'm really not
sure how he made the list Rudy Giuliani
so he's got uh till the end of the day
to pay his ex-wife
plus okay also lawyer fees
250 or 260 000 I think is what is going
on so his ex-wife it not uh not his
second cousin ex-wife uh his ex-wife
this is the other one this is the other
one he's been married like three times
right uh his other one the sanctity of
marriage is their their party's way by
the way yeah yeah uh so basically by the
end of the day he has to cough up this
has been an ongoing thing because they
divorced and
um she's like I want my [ __ ] and uh he
has to pay her this money by the end of
the day or else
he gets uh put in jail wait wait wait
wait wait wait this isn't just like he
he's held in contempt or he yeah or
whatever I mean it is called that but
they're actually gonna they're gonna
slap some cuffs on him they they will
slap they will slap some cuffs on him I
mean like if I if I'm going through it's
if you think he comes up with this money
it's it could you tweet it out here by
the end of the day what what can Rudy
Giuliani do to make 225 000 plus lawyer
fees to avoid being thrown in jail wrong
answers only of course you said but I I
could think of a lot of things that Rudy
Giuliani could do
um I don't know if it would make him 225
000 but right so basically uh yeah the
judge in the in the case said you you
I'm forcing you you got to pay
uh your ex-wife
225 000 or else you will serve jail time
and you know this is a decision that was
made in September
um so he's had I don't know a few weeks
or so uh to pay this back now real
Giuliani he's the guy's grifting money
on his YouTube channel selling cigars
selling slippers selling all I I mean I
I went through his uh his actual let me
see if I can find the original tweet
um but I I once went through all of his
like affiliate marketing where it's like
use code name Rudy and there's like
eight or nine
um
types of affiliate marketing that he
tries to do on his show and
it's
it very it's very sad to see someone who
was once quote-unquote America's mayor
uh now Falls so low here we go 2021 I I
tweeted this out I'll send you the link
but basically he's got to pay this money
back to his ex-wife and the judge like
look you got until the end of the day
the end of the day being October 7th or
else
you go to jail and uh that's that's
where it is right now I mean like
there's there's no way getting around it
um you know I mean the you know in a
lawsuit Judith Giuliani to whom she was
married from 2003 2018 they have no
children claimed her former spouse had
fallen behind on alimony payments
totaling 262 thousand dollars from their
2019 divorce settlement oh look at that
the guy is not actually rich or doesn't
actually want to be a decent human and
agree to the thing that he signed which
is a contract to say I owe you this much
money in alimony after divorce
um
but you know of course what do you
expect it's a fellow Trump
ing did you need me to play this this um
sorry I I have great news for everyone
the Dank Brandon
the Dank Brandon does that mean real
time came through real time it's
happening in real time real time I'm
booting up so let's let me pull up your
um yeah photographic we'll talk about
this and then you can go well we'll go
to the Dank Brandon stuff we all know
that uh
Brandon
um legalized well is trying to legalize
well decriminalize really in essence
um marijuana by by giving pardons to
people with possession
um so we'll get to that part here in
just a second but here here you say Rudy
Giuliani is so broke and joining is
selling products on his YouTube channel
and here's all the things that he's yeah
so we've got my pillow he's selling gold
he's selling a uh a home security system
he's selling some
pharmaceutical non-fda approved product
called Omega XL
I don't know what I forgot what that is
he's selling uh AMAC I some I think it's
American something I forget then he's
he's
pushing you know my pillow he's pushing
famous I think it's a smoke shop and
then also Aficionado which is a Cigar
Magazine because we all know Rudy
Giuliani loves to [ __ ] smoke a stogie
these are just some of the examples that
I found I don't know if he's done more
since then probably but if you text Rudy
to any of these numbers you'll get
yourself a deal for a security system
buying gold
getting my pillow slippers
uh a membership to a smoke shop like
this is the type of person like how far
this guy has fallen
from his position as America's mayor
like I said before and I find it
hilarious I mean we've all seen the
things that have happened to this guy
since then right like he's you know he's
he's on Cameo doing happy birthdays and
stuff he's uh he's promoting uh the
Insurrection and the overthrowing of a
government because he has a bunch of
legal theories that he presented to the
court that the even the judge lawyers
the Trump appointed uh sorry the the
Trump appointed judges laughed in his
face and said you don't actually have
any evidence to prove that the 2020
election was rigged and then Rudy and I
use this term very Loosely as a lawyer
you know because he's well it was at
least a lawyer I think in the state of
New York they took away his license so
he can't actually practice there anymore
that's hilarious
and that's what happens you take an
action there are consequences you [ __ ]
around you find out and Rudy Giuliani is
another example and this is just one of
the things that he's being you know in
trouble for he's so he owes 225 000 to
his ex-wife he's under an investigation
for the Georgia case he's also under
investigation for his involvement in the
January 6 you know leading up to the big
lie
um this guy is he whether he truly
believes these things or he's like [ __ ]
it I'm so far down the rabbit hole I
need to actually
follow through with his group I need to
back Trump no matter what because he's
my only saving grace out of the
situation who knows but
you know America's mayor
uh this guy who was a former lawyer
is
only left two YouTube videos that's all
he can do he's left to YouTube videos
and he's left to affiliate marketing to
be like hey if you guys want to get
these products make sure to text 8842
with the code name Rudy like whoa boy we
are really digging down deep for the
money here uh and I don't think that
he'll be able to get
the 225 here's because here's the other
thing like who are you going to get 225
from that quickly it's got to be a loan
a personal loan actually go to a bank
and I can't imagine a lot of people are
looking at Rudy giuliani's record right
now and being like you know what this
guy's a pretty upstanding dude he'll pay
back his debts no problem
I can't imagine that's actually going to
be the case and so unless there's a
miracle
he's gonna go to jail and until he and
spend his time in jail until he pays off
this amount which will be even more
difficult
once he's actually in jail and doesn't
probably have access to the resources he
might have outside of jail but you know
what the good part if he wants to get
high now before he goes to jail he can
do that and that's all all thanks to
dank Brandon no it's all thanks to dank
what look here stored.d Tony
michaels.com I think I put the um the
link for the t-shirts in the comments
dank Brandon the brand new just hot off
the press is right here live on the show
The Tony Michaels podcast exclusive dank
branded design for the t-shirts store
damn Tony michaels.com
store.d Tony michaels.com get your dink
brand and you can get dark Brandon oh we
still get the dark Brandon over there if
you want the Dank and the dark I mean
honestly you go from you go from green
to red
I don't know I'm saying that both of
them might be a nice Christmas gift for
the holidays hey that's a good idea you
can do both of them yeah
it's dark here's the deal I've got the
shirt set for Dan for dank Brandon but I
promise after the show I will put up the
hoodies
um we'll probably do a sticker and I'll
probably do uh coffee mug
um it's probably what we'll do yeah so
go to
store.donymichaels.com get your brand
t-shirts now as soon as this airs if
you're on the minus touch Channel and
you're watching right now those cups and
stuff are all available at
storesmichaels.com so is the T-shirt
this is hot off the press this is
happening live as we're on there yeah
and we all we all know there's a
republican in your family who actually
smokes absolutely so make sure to get
smokes weed
I don't know I don't know but he ended
up being our Alpha duck yeah um I have a
feeling I know why you put him as our as
our alphabet this week is it because of
that that photo that ended up in the
Louvre is that yeah that's one of the
reasons I mean that was it was that was
the that was the moment in which he kind
of signed his way onto that position so
um I'm gonna I'm gonna find um this this
picture of it at the Louvre and I'd love
to play the clip but we're running out
of time here and we really got to get to
the the winner of the week
um but this picture of the Louvre and
apparently you flew on a plane oh yeah I
got it I got a Super PAC a supersonic
Super PAC Soros oh really yeah yeah
that's right that's what you said
yesterday this was this was all paid
with um um uncle Georgie Uncle Georgie
okay there it is there it is okay paid
for my trip to uh to the Louvre I gotta
and like I said I got I had a private
tour with a small group of other antifa
members and we were able to see the
unveiling of sad DeSantis they called it
sad the Santa Santa called Santa Santos
okay well here is the um here's the the
picture that Gabe took from the Louvre
this is completely real yeah this is
definitely one of our computer
photoshopped or anything like that for
sure and these are the other antiva
members that went with you I guess yeah
yeah
it was George Soros antifa
um free ticket on the on the the space
laser jet that went over to see this
unveiling it was amazing we all and for
dinner we all had uh you know Campbell's
tomato soup oh okay you know for my
family yeah right and tipa loves Soup
cans yeah cans of soup especially tomato
but you see here Ronda Santos is not
liking that the people of of Florida are
so welcoming to a decent empathetic
human being like Joe Biden who would uh
very very low bar very low bar just care
for the American people this picture is
going to be probably the the most famous
Rhonda Santa's picture in history this
is what he's going to go down in history
for and Joe Biden is going to go down in
history for being dank and dark Brandon
that's what that's where we're going
dank Brandon this is uh what what a cook
what a cuckaranda Santa's and the whole
the whole time after the hurricane even
went through you know trying to he tried
to to change the narrative and say oh I
had to ask for this stuff I had to
request it I had to be approved by him
because
all that [ __ ] Joe Biden had that
[ __ ] at the ready and you know what
Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ] himself oh why
you're at the store.the Joni
michaels.com you can grab a Rhonda
Santa's can go [ __ ] himself shirt we
don't mess around with a merch here
anymore dude no if we're on top of it
man like boom boom boom as soon as I
mean yesterday a t-shirt yesterday Jake
Brandon lit up and we're like boom numer
Brandon shirt gotta get the shirt had
the had the artist get the design get it
going do the Dank Brandon thing
so the last the last and final winner
now you're gonna have to put the video
in I don't have the video there loaded
yet if you'll put the um the celebration
video in there and oh just put it in the
Stream yard here but um we've got we've
got Herschel Walker of course this bone
of the week because when you you vote
you decide to do this opponent of the
week and he did a lot of bone-headed
stuff this week and I want to break it
down in just a few minutes because we
don't have a lot of time left here but
holy moly did did he come out strong and
he won the race Herschel Walker sure is
a great running back yeah and he sure is
great at racing he's fast because he
came out of the gate here and this with
this race of bone in the week and he won
immediately it was no contest this week
for me it was and I mean I think I think
we know why right like as soon as Monday
hit with the with the Daily Beast
article and what became a family like a
live showing of Family Feud we saw
Herschel versus Christian Walker
Christian Walker calling out the
hypocrisy of the Republican party you
know calling out his father's lies and
Herschel Walker continuing to double
triple quadruple down on this idea that
I don't know who that woman is I never
paid for that abortion only to then find
out database was like [ __ ] it because
the woman then courageously came forward
and said I will give you more details I
am actually not only did I get an
abortion with Herschel Walker but I am
one of the I am the parent of one of his
children and this is one of the secret
children that we found about we found
out about in June when The Daily Beast
reported that he had an additional three
kids uh that nobody was aware of right
which all this is part of the same
reporting that he's a lying sack of [ __ ]
when it comes to his pathological liar
right and and Christian Walker he's an
[ __ ] okay and he will probably
continue to be an [ __ ] but they even
claim this week that somehow he's an
instrument for the left or something
which is absolutely mind-boggling
because they sent they sent for him like
they did Kanye West wearing the White
lives matter shirt for for years and
years they've loved Christian because
he's always said the stuff that they
want to hear at a person like his mouth
so they can say see like you said
earlier see he's doing it he's saying it
right and it the the token black person
thing is what right gets it just because
again they're like look he's a right a a
black uh gay man although Christian says
he doesn't identify as gay but he likes
men so there's that really weird it's a
weird day but it's the idea that the
Republican Party can claim
this person and say look we aren't
racist we're not homophobic we're not
bigoted look Christian Walker is a a
representation of us accepting him into
our party but that's only because he's
just regurgitating the things that we
want him to say and as soon as he stops
which is what we saw this week which is
the only thing that he said was my
father lied I'm calling out the lies you
can hate me for my beliefs and my
politics and what I say
but I just want to call out the lies of
my father that he promised he would he
would come clean about last year
and it's just for him saying that the
left was like don't betray your family
don't go after your dad you're working
for the left so it's very quickly they
will toss you aside and cast you out
like a leper as soon as you do something
that goes against the narrative that the
Republican party wants you to say
well and I mean that's not surprising
with these folks yeah they'll cast you
out and cast you aside and here's I'm
not going to play the audio but here's
Christian he did several videos
um on social media about how his dad's a
liar and again you got to kind of take
what Christian Walker says at face value
because he's not the most honest person
that there is either on social media but
the guy wasn't lashing out at anyone but
defending himself from the people who
are saying you're a liar and he's like
what no I'm just telling you and and he
was directing it not at liberals he was
directing it he even said you family
values folks yeah like he's saying you
people who have to claim you have family
values that's who I'm talking to like
literally so yeah Ursa Walker there's so
many reasons why he could be the bone
end of the week
um because he did so many boneheaded
things this week yeah like it was like
something tells me something tells me
more is gonna come out this was
definitely a this was an October
surprise not only did we find out that
he had an abortion which is like that
wasn't so surprising me kind of well he
didn't have one he paid for one right he
paid for one right so that that wasn't
to that wasn't totally surprising but
the very surprising effect was that his
son who has been very pro-herschel
Walker from the very beginning love my
dad all the stuff I'm supporting and
stumping for you he said this is it I
can't take anymore right I promise you
we're gonna do this and so he did
continue to support him after the fact
of breaking his promise he then got to a
point of when the article came out
he lied and said not mine didn't pay for
an abortion I don't know the woman and
that is when her that's when Christian
Walker was like okay enough's enough I'm
done well we watched The Family Feud
this week
and it it got Herschel on bonehead of
the week and he won so congratulations
to her wash Herschel Walker our bonehead
of the week
let's give him his dude
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
Herschel Walker thank you for being such
a bonehead you you will probably enjoy
more wins here at the bone of the week
you are a bonehead of the week Champion
um you actually invented bonehead of the
week I'm sure he invented it he probably
and he probably invented the Internet
yeah well we invented this software that
we're using here he came up with YouTube
he was in the room on YouTube
he's the reason why you're watching this
right here right now I I really think I
I should I should be thanking Herschel
Walker for uh for the idea that I had
about bonehead of the week because if if
it were not for those things then we
would not be here right now and I do I
do want to I do want to say I just want
to explain this for a moment Andrew says
how come Tony don't read the chat we do
we have been very pressed for time we're
already 10 minutes over so I apologize
that we did not read the comments during
this segment uh we've just been trying
to rush through the whole show today
right and we're we're way over time but
we're we definitely do not so
yeah and we were trying to get we're
trying to get the Dank Brandon thing
going so it's it's been a hectic morning
here at the Tony Michael's podcast
behind the scenes because literally you
are looking at behind the scenes this is
the scenes and this is behind the scenes
right you're looking at right here so
join us every single Friday for bone of
the week on the Tony Michaels podcast in
the second hour or the replay of bone of
the week on Midas Touch Network make
sure if you're on minus that's Network
to hit the Subscribe button right now
and also go over to Tony Michaels
podcast on YouTube and subscribe there
as well that's where you vote Gabe for
bone and the league on the YouTube
channel also on the Twitter page at Tony
Michaels podcast you can also download
bonehead of the week every single Sunday
on Apple's Spotify Google
if you just want to listen to bonehead
of the week make sure to leave us a
review while you're subscribing on your
favorite directory and don't forget to
go over to store.d michaels.com hot off
the presses dank Brandon merch dank
Brandon merch today store dot
thetonymichaels.com hot off the presses
and exclusive the Tony Michaels podcast
dank Brandon merch dang damn damn
also if you if you didn't like the uh
design or the alpha he was the alpha
this week and you want to tell Rhonda
Santos to go [ __ ] himself in the proper
way you can also grab your Rhonda
Sanchez can go [ __ ] himself merge at
store.t Tony michaels.com
a part of me I feel like we should find
out the address to Rhonda Santos's like
office like where he works yeah we
should send him a shirt no that would be
a great gift wouldn't it what a great
gift I think that would be the Santa's
to get one of those teachers maybe we
send him a uh Rhonda Sanchez go [ __ ]
himself and we send him a dark Brandon
and then a cinema dank brand you know
what we could do we may I don't know if
we can do this or not maybe we should
put that art on a pair of white rubber
boots I'm saying he would probably wear
them anywhere and everywhere he goes
everyone
um thank you thank you for joining us
for this edition of bone end of the week
everyone on the Tony Michaels podcast
stick around we have a few announcements
but if you're on the mind and such
Network thanks for joining us we'll see
you next week on bonehead of the week
foreign
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
yeah well
I mean it's gonna be a great weekend uh
for a lot of people and and the reason
why more than anything is because a lot
of people now uh don't have to worry
about their lives going forward because
of a simple position of marijuana where
they got federal charges and they get
they gotta put it on every single
application every single where they go
it follows them around forever and ever
and most employers these days are like
really marijuana what the hell
um so now now these people won't have to
have to change their entire lives their
entire way of walking around trying to
get a job or or an apartment renting
somewhere
um they'll be able to do this and it's
all because
of dank Brandon so make sure to go to
store.d Tony michaels.com
grab your dank Brandon I promise now now
again there's just the T-shirt there
right now yeah but more will come or
more will come and I I gave you guys a
few options of greens
um to pick from this black there's the
heavy metal there's several green colors
that you can get
but I will do a hoodie and now the
hoodies I don't think I may or may not
be able to do green what do you think we
should definitely do a green hoodie if
we can yeah why not yeah so we'll do the
hoodies we'll do should we put it on
coffee mugs or should we put it on like
a metal sign we do put on a metal sign
we can do metal signs now should we do a
metal sign I don't know I mean you got
to see I was thinking about doing that
Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ] himself metal
sign I think a lot of people would like
that they can hang it up on the wall
yeah I don't know maybe we should send
one of those to Ron the metal signs that
way he could hang it up in his office oh
just like nail it up on the wall yeah
yeah it's not a real good Florida feel
to it yeah yeah yeah yeah that design
you guys know what I'm talking about the
design has a great feel full or to feel
too look at it Rhonda Santos can go [ __ ]
him so so maybe we'll put that on the um
on a metal sign maybe we'll put dark
brand on our metal sign this one's been
going like hotcakes the Liberty shirt
the freedom to oppress the rights of
other people is not Liberty you [ __ ] any
[ __ ] um that one's been going on [ __ ]
cakes dude guys thank you you're the
best audience in the world thank you for
all your support we run on it
um we you guys have been enjoying the
merch that's why we keep doing more and
more because you guys are really
enjoying it and we enjoy when you guys
uh like our art and our ideas that we
put out on t-shirts and hoodies and wear
it around and and we the likes the
subscribes it's all up the audience is
up the numbers are up you guys are here
you guys are listening every single
weekday Monday through Friday and it's
and you guys are in the chat you're
engaging and we can't always read every
single comment in the chat but we got
our moderators there they try to point
out the things that uh and bring our
attention to so thank MJ Margie and
Robin the three great moderators in the
YouTube chat give them some love as well
so I'm sure they might be getting danky
this weekend as well I don't know but if
you can
um support us at Tony Michaels dot live
if you can give us a one-time tip or a
monthly tip you can set it up just set
it and forget it we love all of you have
a safe have a safe weekend smoking it up
I know you [ __ ] are going to be
doing this I'm in a good a good lesson
for the day is uh remember that a bong a
day keeps the doctor away
well thank you for joining us have a
great and safe weekend when you're
smoking and token
everyone
we'll see you next Monday same time same
place Surfside [ __ ] you've been
listening to the Tony Michaels podcast
in your face commentary of current
events and political news no rules No
Boundaries I think we've made that
perfectly clear we hope you enjoyed the
show and we'll be back soon in the
meantime follow toning on social media
at the Tony Michaels and until next time
raise a fist and repeat after me
[ __ ] them [ __ ] em
[Music]
Murphy's meal Barn had asked Beacon